[Musica]
ciao a tutti oggi vi parlerò della
sicurezza stradale e per essere precisi
vi parlerò della sicurezza sulle due
ruote e di come la mia invenzione
riuscirà a cambiare per sempre il
tradizionale casco per moto che voi
conoscete una delle mie passioni sono
anche i motori perché riescono a darti
una sensazione di libertà e spesso
aiutano a scaricare le tensioni che
accumuliamo nel corso della giornata
magari abbiamo avuto una giornata
difficile al lavoro o semplicemente la
città ci sta soffocando e sentiamo
quindi il bisogno di un bel viaggio da
soli e lontano dai pensieri
supponendo un viaggio sulle due ruote
come ben sappiamo spesso può essere
pericoloso basta un attimo di
distrazione un asfalto bagnato o una
strada sdrucciolevole per farsi
veramente male
ora per farvi capire al meglio cosa
intendo con questo casco con la mia
invenzione a chi a chi serve a cosa fa
di preciso mi dovrò portare insieme a me
in un viaggio per farvi capire
esattamente cosa intendo quindi ora vi
chiedo per un attimo di pensare a un
luogo ok un luogo bellissimo in cui ci
siete stati chi conoscete bene un luogo
panoramico ok e vi chiedo di immaginarvi
di trovarvi in questo momento lì in
sella alla vostra moto anche chi non
guida la moto chi non l'ha mai guidata
questa è la vostra prima volta
ok quindi immaginate va bene ci siamo
ora state percorrendo questa strada
panoramica in questo luogo bellissimo
però come tutti sappiamo spesso durante
il tragitto durante escursione può
accadere un imprevisto nel nostro caso
l'imprevisto può accadere durante questa
nostra camminata subito dopo una curva
per colpa dell'asfalto dissestato altri
condizioni climatiche cadiamo dalla moto
abbattiamo la testa e stiamo quasi per
perdere i sensi
ci sentiamo il peso della moto sopra
siamo immobili non siamo in grado di
chiamare nessuno siamo in grado di
uscirne fuori siamo bloccati siamo
intrappolati e stiamo per
perdere i sensi ora ci troviamo in un
posto poco trafficato dove è difficile
essere avvistati quindi noi non siamo in
grado di chiamare nessuno è praticamente
siamo bloccati
allora ho ragionato molto su questa cosa
e devo dirvi che più ci pensavo e più mi
nervosi perché non riuscivo ad accettare
di non sentirmi al sicuro sulla mia moto
quindi sul ragionamento che potevo fare
all'età di 18 anni quando sviluppa in
questo casco e sulla base di quello che
vi ho appena raccontato sono riuscito ad
ideare progettare e successivamente
sviluppare un casco o meglio una
tecnologia che incorporata su un casco
possa funzionare da componente salvavita
quindi non parliamo più del
semplicissimo casco che offre una
protezione passiva al momento
dell'impatto ma stiamo parlando di un
casco intelligente un casco che oltre ad
offrire la protezione durante l'impatto
svolge anche una funzione post incidente
cosa vuol dire posti incidente vuol dire
qualcosa che ti possa aiutare in qualche
modo nell'istante dopo nell'istante in
cui teso sei sotto choc se magari senza
ai perse sensi quindi sei immobilizzato
e quindi questo casco riesce a svolgere
una funzione al posto tuo
completamente autonomo quindi sa già
come reagire nel migliore dei modi per
garantire a te maggiore sicurezza
quindi in grado di rilevare la
collisione con l'asfalto quindi capire
l'imprevisto sapere il punto esatto dove
ti trovi localizzati e mandare una
richiesta di soccorso in pochissimi
istanti senza il minimo intervento da
parte di chi lo indossa
ora ritornando a quello che vi ho fatto
immaginare ok quindi siete ancora
bloccati sotto la moto siete immobili e
non riuscita a reagire con l'esterno ma
per fortuna
avete il casco avete questo casco
intelligente che se n'è accorto che
siete in difficoltà perché siete caduti
per terra e abete va tutto alla testa
quindi in questo istante il casco vista
geolocalizzando quindi sta comunicando
quei satelliti e sta dicendo bene io
questo mio utilizzatori si trova in
questo punto esatto in questo momento
lui ma da un sms
numero o ha più numeri scelte dall
utilizzatore al momento dell'acquisto
specificando la posizione la condizione
dell'utilizzatore e che abbiamo bisogno
di aiuto che ci troviamo in difficoltà
avvisando così parenti amici o chiunque
altro che abbiamo bisogno del loro aiuto
così facendo i soccorritori potranno
intervenire immediatamente e di
conseguenza ridurremmo tempi di ricerca
ed intervento
ora quello che aveva contato per adesso
è soltanto quello che fa di base in
quanto il casco
grazie ad altri sensori moduli e
componentistiche è in grado di svolgere
altre funzioni ancora più smart
come ad esempio può essere il
rilevamento della stanchezza monitorando
il battito delle ciglia oppure
rilevamento della distrazione alla guida
monitorando l'orientamento del dove il
guidatore
oppure ancora per capire la gravità
della situazione può monitorare le stato
vitale tramite il battito cardiaco
capire quindi in che situazione ci siamo
e come siamo messi
dando quindi un indice di gravità un
report completo al numero predefinito
che noi abbiamo scelto in questo momento
il casco è soggetto a diversi test con
la collaborazione di un grande
produttore italiano e stiamo cercando di
fare tutto il possibile per riuscire a
lanciare questo prodotto previsioni per
l'anno 2019
per adesso è tutto grazie a tutti per
l'attenzione
[Applauso]